hi everybody this is brian eisenberg
welcome to always be testing the power
of small incremental continuous
improvement to improve the quality of
your marketing
for the last almost 12 years i've been
focused on helping companies improve
their marketing and improve their
conversion rates
and it comes to no surprise to me in
today's marketplace that a lot of things
that are people are getting excited
about and getting focused on are still
not the very things that i've been
preaching for the last decade
and so what i wanted to share with you
today was a little bit of a story um
that started just about
10 years ago or so
when we were working with one of our
very first paying customers his name was
jason cement he was the ceo of
magmal.com
and uh he was uh trying to improve his
business and and get more sales and he
was talking to an incubator and trying
to raise money uh because a competitor
of his e-news
had just finished raising close to a
hundred million dollars in funding
of course to get lots of people to
subscribe to magazines from their
website
and the one thing for sure is back then
both websites really weren't very good
um but at the end of the day you know if
you had to compare no funds to 100
million dollars you'd assume that the
site with 100 million dollars would be a
huge success of course you know they can
invest in all kinds of marketing efforts
all kinds of innovative ideas
and and spend more on driving traffic
than the smaller site with no funding
well we work with jason um and started
making some small changes to his website
added a unique value proposition cleaned
up the navigation
slowly started making changes to the
color scheme eventually a couple years
later we redesigned the website and you
can see it looks a lot more professional
back then um you know we talked about
all the great benefits that he has to
help make people dive right into some of
the key magazines that were
the main purchases
and
we took his conversion rate from a 1.11
conversion rate so a little over one
percent of the people came purchasing
from him to a
4.93 conversion rate so almost a five
times impact on his conversion rate
where at the very same time as this
success that jason was achieving
uh e news unfortunately had to regret
people that the enewswood.com website
had been closed
the 100 million dollars of course and
all the great innovation and great
marketing
couldn't make people
buy from them
uh and in the end jason's still in
business today and the main reason is
because he focused on this concept of
continuous improvement he just said look
i can keep improving experience for my
customers improve my conversion rate
make my traffic more profitable and
that my dollars stretch further and of
course that was a huge success for him
now this is not a new concept in fact w
edward deming who sent by the us
government after world war ii to japan
to help their economy prosper uh taught
them the concept of total quality
management of quality control and
improving the experience um that people
had with the their manufacturing in fact
deming's whole premise was about
improving the quality will reduce your
expenses and
improve the quality of your experience
your workers and
gaining market share and of course
that's exactly what we're trying to do
and it's the same kind of concept that
we'll be talking about today that will
help your marketing and your business
improve by focusing in on the right
aspects
see in most organizations the way they
make decisions around marketing and
improving their business is around what
my good friend avinash kaushik likes to
call the hippo right uh the highest paid
person's opinion in the room uh versus
being data driven and of course you know
whenever we're around hippos there's
lots and lots of fat around
but it certainly does not answer
the right questions by being totally
focused on the data and making smart
decisions and of course there's the
other extreme where you're so focused on
the data whereas in this scott adams
cartoon uh you need a dashboard
application to track your key metrics
that will you'll have more data to
ignore when you make your decisions
based on company politics will the data
be accurate okay let's pretend that
matters so i want to question you to
kind of be careful not go one extreme
with other where everything's based on
gut or intuition and the other extremes
always has to be based on data you need
to kind of balance this out to make sure
you're not always focused on the wrong
aspects of this
and what i learned over all these years
is that the same aspects that help
people focus on weight loss believe it
or not um are also the same ones that
make them effective in conversion
optimization in fact since um april 2009
i've lost over 55 pounds
by focusing in on doing small things
small meals small rewards small bits of
exercise and increasing them ever so
much
and this small thing that focused on
trimming the fat it's not like i've
gotten rid of anything that i really
enjoy because that's what a lot of
people are concerned about when they
hear the terms trim the fact that you're
going to cut out quality no in fact what
we're going to focus on is increasing
your corporate metabolism
and improving the quality of your
customer experience
and by doing that the key is about
focusing in on the people
see optimization is about understanding
people's motivation what makes them want
to do the things they do and influencing
to take the right actions it's not about
mathematical models and statistics and
an analysis don't get me wrong i love
all of those and they're all important
in their play but at the end if you
can't focus on what matters more to
people like making decisions between
eating a healthy snack like an apple or
you know
rich delicious truffles
you're really not hitting the mark
you're not going to get it by testing
you know granny smith apples with
cortland apples you really have to have
these big wider extremes to make sure
you're hitting on all the right notes
see what the japanese realized very
early on with weather deming was that
this process of continuous improvement
uh kaizen
uh or six sigma is really really
powerful improving um your business see
if 50 years ago you had the opportunity
to invest in either general motors or
toyota for sure you would have invested
in general motors they had all the
marketing muscle all the great
innovation they had all the models
everybody wanted and toyota's vehicles
just weren't all that great
but by focusing on the continuous
improvement process there's a great
story of when ford was working with
mazda and they were trying to create
transmissions
and they gave the exact specifications
the exact same materials at the end
people loved the mazda transmissions and
weren't crazy about the four
transmissions only because their
tolerance levels for what they'd accept
as a failure rate
made the ride so much smoother and in
fact even 30 years ago people didn't
want cars necessarily were the japanese
made but today
it's the largest share of the market and
unfortunately uh general motors for
example is dying from cardiac arrest
because they have not been able to trim
the fat so hopefully today i will tell
you how to move from just planning your
marketing which is what every marketer
loves to do to not only measuring the
marketing which of course is critical
today and today we have measurements
everywhere but how to focus on the key
aspect of improving your marketing
because ultimately that is the key to
success you need all three steps in
continuous process being that treadmill
of continuous improvement to get the
success that you need in fact in the
last decade all the companies have been
hugely successful have made marks and
and become well branded are all
companies that focus on these two
aspects
customer experience
and continuous improvement
in fact some of you may even recognize
this page um this is the first landing
page for amazon.com and they really are
the poster child for improving customer
experience online and focusing in on the
customer in fact i think one of the
greatest examples of amazon.com is first
of all how they leveraged what i call
the tom sawyer effect right where tom
invited all his friends to come help him
paint uh the wall while he did very
little work well of course amazon got
lots of people to come in and submit
reviews to their products leveraging the
first social media word of mouth
in terms of building their sales vehicle
but more than that they've always
focused on improving the converse rate
no matter how small
it is they focused on improving little
details on their website in fact at any
given time on amazon you can have up to
200 tests running
one of those classic examples is one of
my favorites is just this one little
area what i call the ready to buy area
all the stuff around their add to cart
button that they've evolved over the
years and again not that ad car buttons
are the most impactful things in the
world but if amazon can focus on this
over and over again throughout the years
they realize there's always
opportunities small gains that are
continued to be had by focusing in on
this area
now this one screenshot is taken from
the late 90s where they used to
everybody used to be concerned back then
if you hit the wrong button you blow up
the world start war games or something
like that and you'll notice amazon had
the lock on there they talked about
shopping with us is safe guaranteed and
the hyperlink to that on the button
itself it said at the shopping cart you
can always remove it later and of course
i want to remind people that they were
buying from amazon.com
a couple years later they modified that
and they now started offering their true
innovation which was obviously their one
click and they were able to remove the
lock from there they removed the
shopping classes safe guaranteed but
they still kept the language you can
always remove it later on the button
again the point of action assurance
which we'll talk a lot about throughout
the course really made a big difference
on their button and of course they use a
little bit more provocative headline
than buy from amazon.com and changed it
to ready to buy
shortly afterwards
they got rid of the you can always
remove it later from the buttons and
move it to underneath the ready to bind
so you can always cancel later what's
interesting is they made the buttons
smaller in that whole space a little
shorter only so they can focus on
selling their used items what was
interesting here is they actually
reduced their conversion rate but
increased their revenue because selling
used books means they didn't have to
warehouse and have people touch it all
they had to do is sell email and collect
fees so they were able to sacrifice a
little bit of the customer experience
for increased revenue that's always the
balance you need to have
shortly thereafter they did a redesign
they added a little more shadowing
battling to their site and of course to
their button they started promoting a9
wasn't a huge success and just a couple
of years ago they added now a pull down
to their quantity menu because in case
you wanted to order more than one item
so again just one area continuous
improvement over the years to improve
their conversion rate
but the key to all this and again you
can't test everything all the time
is focusing in on prioritization and i
was very fortunate very early on to work
with a good friend of mine by the name
sam dekker who's now the chief marketing
officer for bizarre voice who provides
customer reviews and and social uh
commerce platform for retailers and
manufacturers
and what he did is he asked us to
analyze the dell ecommerce website the
business consumer website and come up
with a list of recommendations that he
can improve just before he was ready to
leave that position to move on to
another position
and we went ahead and analyzed the site
we probably gave him report that was
somewhere between 16 70 pages of all the
different things he can improve and what
he did is he went through every single
one of those and said look
i'm going to prioritize them based on
the resources that it's going to need
the impact it's going to have what
resources are going to need and also
what is it going to matter to our
organization and what he came up with is
this one test which wasn't the most
impactful test but it really was a test
that was going to get people at dell
thinking differently about their
customers and how they go through their
purchase process as opposed to just
changing things around for the sake of
of improving conversion rates randomly
and if you know the configurator you
know when you get multiple options as
you're trying to shop
um they used to have the words learn
more and we recommended that they change
those words to help me choose because
when you're ready to shop you don't want
to learn you want to buy so you want
them to help you choose
and that one change has accounted for
tens of millions of dollars over the
years
and again nothing on the content
afterwards changed but it got people
thinking about wow the words my
customers are thinking about matter in
the purchase process
now the way you prioritize always fall
down to these three things number one
your resources right what do you have
available to make changes if you don't
have designers don't make design changes
make copy changes
if you don't have programmers you know
make design changes that's okay make
whatever you have available possible and
whatever you can invest you don't have
to invest you know 40 hours a week or 80
hours a week of your team into
improvements to focus on 5 hours or 10
hours or 20 hours as long as you're
focusing a little bit of your resources
into it the second piece is you need
people and we'll talk about what kind of
people you need but you need people who
are going to be able to make the changes
identify the changes really really
critical
and thirdly it always comes down to your
culture what's going to matter to your
culture it may not be the most impactful
test but if it's going to make a
difference in the way your organization
thinks or your hippo thinks
absolutely critical to focus in on that
culture aspect
but where the biggest breakdown happens
in older organizations in terms of
conversion optimization is in their
budgets see unfortunately in today's
marketplace as well it's been for the
last 40 years everybody's focused on
bringing in traffic like if we bring
more people it's a numbers game and
eventually if we have more people we'll
sell more people that's sort of true but
unfortunately it's like pouring water
into a leaky bucket people will
eventually leave and unless you fill up
that bucket
you lose more more of those people and
they have an experience with your brand
that may not be positive so instead of
focusing all your money on pay-per-click
and pay-per-call and banner advertising
and affiliate marketing and email
marketing you need to focus on usability
testing and web analytics and
interpreting that web analytics and
testing and copywriting and improving
your internal search and all the other
aspects that improve the online
experience once they reach your website
as opposed to all the things that are
off your website and when you focus a
little bit on that budget on the
conversion optimization you're bound to
get better results see most people don't
have a traffic problem in fact i had a
prospect come up to me and told me
he had sixty thousand total visitors to
his website and i found out his traffic
was extremely well targeted only about
10 percent of the people coming to his
website were leaving immediately that
means they had a very low bounce rate
that he was able to record in his
analytics report right people came and
they stuck to the website that kept
clicking
now what that means if only 10 percent
were disqualified
that left them with about 54 000
qualified visitors and its typical
marketplace depending on how complex
your sale
it usually is about 30 to 70 percent of
your customers are in the marketplace to
purchase today or this week or whatever
the timeline is for your purchase cycle
in fact mcafee did some great research
that showed in digital window shopping
or the time it takes from adding an item
to your cart until you actually purchase
is roughly a day and a half so not
surprising 30 70 are in the market i
said that left them with about 30 000
potential buyers and unfortunately only
a thousand of them were actually
completing their orders so the
opportunity to improve the experience
and improve the conversion rate it
happens with these extra 29 000 people
and if all they did is focused on
improving the conversion rate for 500
more people to convert or a thousand
they nearly double their business
you don't need to focus on driving more
traffic at this point just on improving
the experience of the people that come
to your website
now the three key resources you need in
order to make this happen is i said
number one the people you need someone
from marketing need someone to own the
process someone who's going to make the
business decisions and prioritize what
happens first you also need someone to
analyze the data and tell you where your
biggest opportunities for improvement
are
you also need your creative resources
your graphic designers your copywriters
your flash people and you'll need some
level of technical resources to maybe
copy and paste some code um of your
testing tags and your analytics tags
into here to make sure you can make the
changes that you need to
the second thing you need is the tools
and um unfortunately today the tools
aren't an obstacle
you can get google website optimizer for
free and it can test hundreds of
different things on your website and
there's other great tools that we talk
about further in our course that you can
use to improve your conversion rate many
of them free or low cost
but ultimately what you really need is
the process and the process is what we
plan to teach you
through the course of conversion
optimization you need a way to go from
plan
measure to improve and then back again
and that process is a process i
developed with my brother jeffrey
eisenberg and john cordova on tv
who's a good friend of mine and former
rocket scientist for nasa
and the questions those
amazingly simple are incredibly powerful
the first question is
who are we trying to persuade is much
easier to persuade someone or get them
to take action when you know who you're
talking about now if you know all the
details about someone's obviously much
easier and and an ideal situation you
can personalize your offer
but
many cases online we don't have all that
level of detail so we're going to talk
about a process that's more akin to
personalization and i'll explain that a
little bit more detail a couple of
moments
the second question is what action do we
want them to take in other words do we
want to subscribe to to become a lead to
register to download a white paper to
forward a link what is the action we
want them to take and not only that big
macro action of this buy or or subscribe
but also the little micro actions what
actually wanted to take on this page on
our website and on the next page on our
website and on the next page of the
website and then number three what
action do they want to take
your visitors on your website because
they decided to be there they're in
control of the experience and they're
there to accomplish a task whatever that
task may be and our job is to marry our
goals with their goals and give them the
information they need in order to feel
confident that they're accomplishing
their task and taking action they want
to
all in the while taking the action we
want them to take
now the way we personalize this is
human psychology
human beings since the beginning of time
have been hardwired left brain right
brain right more logical approach more
emotional approach we also have
preferences in terms of the way we
gather information in the way we make
decisions whether we're more deliberate
or whether we make decisions quickly or
gather information quickly
i call these four areas competitive
spontaneous methodical humanistic now if
you follow kirsty if you follow young
myers-briggs hippocrates they've all had
different names for them but they all
basically fall into the four same
categories of emotional logical quick
and deliberate
now
it's interesting because we see these
patterns all over the place in fact
usability guru jacob nielsen did an eye
tracking analysis on the us census
bureau website and when he did his
analysis he identified there were four
unique patterns of eye tracking
now didn't surprise me or my staff when
we looked at this because we said
of course therefore four basic human
hard wires or operating systems
essentially
in the way we gather information
and so if you look at these four and
we'll look at them in detail you can see
this one which is the competitive
pattern they stick towards the top of
the page maybe look at a couple of
bullet points grab the information
quickly and logically no emotions
involved here
the methodical
they are slow
deliberate
but
very logical they look at all the
different data points they spend time
looking at all the different data points
look at how they look through all the
navigation
really really critical to deal with
these people in the most appropriate way
again methodicals
deliberate and logical spontaneous
people they're attracted to the
interaction pictures of people and you
can see they hit right to those points
they're attracted to those kind of
things
and then lastly the humanistic person
who again is a little bit more
deliberate but they're emotionally
involved okay
and what we do with this is we create
our personas our predictive models are
going to help us understand the buying
process and understand what our
customers want to achieve now you can
create simple personas as
you know people who know about our brand
people who don't know about it and
people who know about what they're
purchasing from us people who don't know
repeat visitors and new visitors uh
people who are competitive or
spontaneous or methodical humanistic
some very basic segmentation people come
from search versus people come from
social media all of the things can give
us different aspects of how to think
about what we're trying to achieve or
you can combine a lot of complex uh
details about them to create robust
personas real rich narratives that can
be multiple pages long that feel to your
research organization or to your
you know senior executives that they've
very very very detailed and
understanding of who these customers are
and help us build empathy to understand
what content they're going to need in
order to fill the gap of information
they need in order to take that action
in the persuasion architecture process
now the nice thing today is it's very
easy to test everything right with
something like google website optimizer
you can go ahead and you can test a
headline to see if it could be appeal
more to a competitive personality type
or you can go ahead and you can test an
image to see if it'll appeal better to
your spontaneous personality type you
can test anything on the page any copy
or creative
and what we can do with this process
though is make it simple for us to
identify what to test
for example we were working with
overstock.com several years ago and they
had this one page their movie page where
they had a
91.8 percent abandonment rate that means
almost 92 out of every hundred people
came to this website left it immediately
and if you look at the page closely
they list a whole bunch of different
movies their top ten
lord of the ring was a popular movie at
the time what the coming soon the new
releases the featured picks
and the typical way that most people
would approach in conversion
optimization improving this page is they
use multivariate testing they take every
single section of the site
and change it over come up with a bunch
of variations around it move it around
and hope that at some point they get an
improvement conversion rate that's
certainly one approach to do this
unfortunately what i find when most
people do this
is that they're doing what i call slice
and dice optimization for every single
one of those segments you need to come
up with different versions of your
creative you need to come up with all
these variations you need to invest
traffic to see all these variations in
order to determine which one is the best
winner and what happens is it invests a
lot of resources that most people can't
afford to use up i can imagine that most
people who listening to this
don't have endless resources so let's
use our persuasion architecture process
to identify a simpler way to improve
this page
so now we look at this page and we look
at the four basic personality types
that's all we're going to do on this one
we're going to look at spontaneous
people
spontaneous people when they're looking
at movies they look to for the top
sellers and new releases and as you can
see on this page this page is a great
job talking about the top ten the
feature picks the new releases
this is what
this is heaven for the spontaneous
people we'll have to do anything to
improve the page for them
the humanistic people they care about
reviews now overstock.com had hundreds
of thousands of reviews and
unfortunately none of them were going to
appear on this page but in order to get
them on this page we were going to have
to involve what i like to call the
business prevention unit or the i.t
group so we're going to hold off a
little bit on them eventually we'll get
across to improving the experience for
them
now the methodicals we know they're slow
and deliberate
and logical they'll take their time
looking around to figure out where to
click to go next and there actually is a
place where they can click to dig in by
genre but the competitors are the ones
that concerned me if you remember the
eye tracking studies they showed you
with jacob nielsen the other ones who
search quickly at the top of the page
they look for the actor the title if
they don't see new what they're looking
for how to get what they're looking for
they're out of there
and what we mechanized right away is the
top of the page right next to the search
engine there is a banner whenever you
put the two things together people think
they're associated and what happened is
that when people looked at the search
engine they associated kids tiles for
learning and fun
with the search engine that maybe they
were going to look for kids titles
and so i called up the ceo that night
and i said patrick
please change the graphic on that page
so we can appeal to the competitives all
i want you to do is take a before and
change it with this one after one
graphic and that one graphic was worth
almost 25
million dollars it increased their
revenue by 5 on a 480 million dollars
every day did not fill that hole
they were losing almost 68
this is the power of small incremental
improvements yes this was a big
improvement but focusing in on the
little details by making small changes
opposed to massive changes you can get
great results
now this doesn't only apply just to
websites you can also do this for all of
your marketing in fact here's a great
example that happened with office depot
they were going ahead and they launched
this concept called the penny pranks
where they took this gentleman and they
put a hidden camera on him and they went
around buying things with pennies now
what they did is they launched
bunches of different videos to figure
out which was going to be the most
effective which one got the most views
which one got the most comments which
one people watched the most using uh
youtube insights and they finally
settled on one that was going to be the
winner based on all these metrics
now they couldn't descript this any
better um
and if you've ever been to some of the
stories that happened in new york you
might even experience something like
this and what happened is the whole time
they were running this campaign
they went ahead and they promoted on
their website with the power to the
penny
again of course because as people were
watching those videos and passing along
and sharing them they were coming to the
website and was producing great results
and then once they found the winner on
youtube and online they launched it as
part of their television campaign
much more cost effective instead of
spending millions on a tv commercial and
they don't know if it was going to
perform launch it online check your
metrics and then declare a winner
this again illustrates the power of
small
details of focusing in on those small
increases see which one's going to
incrementally give you a better result
and it's kind of like compounding
interest right you can go ahead and
improve your conversion rate by as
little as five percent a month and it
doesn't sound like it's a lot and it may
only take a few hours a month to get to
that point but at the end of the year
you'll have increased your conversion
rate by over 80 percent that's almost
doubled your business just by focusing
in on a five percent increase
every single month
the key is you need to focus on
improving your corporate metabolism
every day you need to focus on improving
your marketing whether it's 10 minutes
here and 20 minutes there you can always
identify and through this course we'll
show you how you can identify those
opportunities where you can identify
those opportunities and then what to do
in order to improve it
to focus in on your personas and on your
customers to give them the right
experience
to become
great
see execution is not a one-time event of
launching a campaign or launching a new
website it's not a one-time push towards
achieving that goal
rather it's a way of life as guy
kawasaki said it's about continuously
focusing on improving the experience and
grabbing more market share
i wish you the best of luck because
persuasion architecture works the
process has been working for well over a
decade and will continue to work the
question is will you work the process